if you want to win on youtube this year
you're going to regret
just making the same content you made
yesterday yesterday's
home runs will not win today's game
and so think about leveling up your
content one percent per video
and over a year's time you're going to
be amazed by the level your content is
at
welcome to the think marketing podcast
the number one podcast
where we help you grow your influence on
youtube and then turn that influence
into a high impact and a high profit
online business
my name is heather torres and if you're
new here welcome we deliver a brand new
podcast to you every single tuesday
so make sure you subscribe wherever
you're consuming this content from
and i'm excited because today's featured
information
is from sean cannell and he's jumping
into the five changes that you need to
make on youtube
this year and if you don't make them
you're gonna regret it because youtube
is an
ever-changing organism and we want to
make sure that you know what is working
right now so grab your notebook lean in
and let's get into
today's podcast
[Music]
if you are just starting your youtube
channel and you're under a thousand
subscribers or a hundred thousand
subscribers i've got some good
news for you recent updates to youtube
actually
give you an advantage if you're brand
new and in this video
i'm actually gonna be revealing some
changes we've been observing
from our research at think media and all
of the content that we post
and talk about really five of the pivots
we are making this year to get more
views and to break through the algorithm
on youtube these are some changes that
if you don't make these i believe you
will regret it
later and the first one is that
subscribers are
overrated yes people's main
passion in fact think about it don't you
want to get that silver play button and
get that gold play button
you know grow that youtube channel and
maybe have the quote unquote bragging
rights of how many subscribers
do you have well here's the thing
subscribers in 2021 and beyond are
actually overrated and here's a couple
ways to think about it
number one is a lot of times we think
man if somebody could just shout me out
if i could just get a shout out from mr
beast one of the largest most successful
youtubers
i could get like a million subscribers
overnight but the question
is would those be the right subscribers
and imagine you created
vegan cooking videos and you were gonna
do a tofu
scramble video and now you've got these
a million new subscribers from mr beast
you post your new video but guess what
the majority of them they're actually
not interested in that video so they
don't click on it
well here's how the youtube algorithm
works now
if your subscribers pass over that video
in their feed if that video is
tested on their homepage or suggested to
them and they don't want to click on it
then youtube actually kills the
distribution of the video
they actually stop it from reaching
anyone so actually subscribers
can be a vulnerability if you have the
wrong subscribers
then they can actually stop your videos
from reaching
people so your goal is ultimately to
have the right
subscribers and the good news is that if
you're starting from scratch
you have the ability to attract the
right subscribers for your content with
your goal
of always uploading videos that the most
of your subscribed audience
wants to click on and watch think about
it this way
never upload a video that your
subscribers
didn't subscribe for you know i saw this
proved out with janelle
elena who recently on youtube grew to
1.3 million subscribers in a matter of
weeks
this also tells me that if you make the
right content
and you understand the target audience
you're trying to reach
then that video will be able to be
distributed across the platform and
whether you have zero subscribers or a
million subscribers
it really is now based on the merit of
any individual video
and a couple of the metrics we're
looking at is the click-through rate
that's when someone has a chance to
click on the video do they click on it
again if you've got the wrong
subscribers and they don't even if it's
a good thumbnail
great title but they don't click on it
well then youtube kills the video
the opposite is true if your subscribers
and people like them and people on the
platform
love a topic love a video and click on
it like crazy that'll help the video
be spread and shared and then the other
one is like average view duration it's
just how long are people watching the
video again
if your subscribers are kind of like so
so like let me check this out they click
on your newest video
but they kind of go this is boring or i
gave it a shot but i didn't really care
about this again if it's not
a topic if it's not content that they're
passionate about watching and they don't
hang out on the video
average view duration watch time minutes
they don't spend time on the video
then again youtube will kill
the distribution and it being
recommended in the algorithm so
subscribers are overrated
you don't want to be focusing on the
subscribers you want to be getting clear
on your target audience and you really
want to understand their
psychology if you make the right video
at the right time with the right title
and the right
thumbnail for the right audience with
some great content then that
video can spread like crazy and
ultimately this reminds us that it's
good to have a niche channel
you know this is a lesson we've kind of
learned the hard way at think media
because even though we're getting some
incredible results and
in 2020 we had over 40 million video
views
so we're doing a lot of things right but
you know think media being an older
channel
think about it people have subscribed
for all types of different reasons they
click subscribe for a camera review
they click subscribe for a live stream
switcher review they click subscribe for
some youtube tips like we do a lot of
different topics so
when we release a new video if our
subscribers
don't want to click on it or just are
not interested in the topic they're like
i'm sure it's good i just don't care
well then potentially that hurts the
distribution of that video
so don't worry if you don't have
subscribers focus on understanding your
larger target audience
and making the best possible video
because you're one video away
from changing your life and business
with
youtube with a breakout video hey number
two
is shorter is greater than longer
this year you know one of the changes
we've been thinking about
is making shorter videos on youtube
and this actually doesn't replace longer
videos it's just that
we suggest you have shorter videos
in your library of content that you're
publishing
and that you are intentionally trying to
make your videos
quicker more punchy delivering value
at a faster pace you know we get this
short form content trend really from
tick tock reels
shorts on linkedin shorts on facebook
and
what we're seeing is that people are
able to deliver value on say instagram
reels
really quick i mean you see a 15 second
reel and someone's like
here's a quick tax tip that'll save you
money this year they tell you what it is
and they're like follow and subscribe
and so the reality is value can be
delivered really quickly whether it's
entertainment
whether it's tips whether it's education
whatever it is that you do
so when you think about a shorter video
think about how you can make your video
half short and twice strong think about
how you can make your video
more like tick-tock more like 15 or 30
seconds
and think about maybe making it a series
of tick tocks so for example
at think media if we have five tips to
deliver in our short form content
we're trying to think about how we could
deliver those five tips in two and a
half minutes in three minutes
we're trying to think about how we can
do list videos that are maybe ten tips
but deliver all ten in four and a half
minutes because it's almost like putting
a bunch of tick tocks together and
if more teaching needs to be done or if
a certain part needs more time for
you know a little bit of connecting and
whatnot you don't want to seem rushed or
seem crazy in the video but i think it's
just the principle that when possible
make the video
shorter i mean just consider your own
behavior i know for me if i'm looking to
solve a problem and i type in a search
in youtube
and i look at the homepage rank videos
there
and i see there's a 15 minute option a
32 minute option
and a nine minute option and the
thumbnail's good and i look like i wanna
click on i'm gonna go with the nine
minute i mean
i might actually discover that it was a
wasted nine minutes and now i gotta
watch the longer
version to really discover but if
possible
i'm gonna go for the shorter version and
if you're newer to youtube if you're
trying to break out on youtube if you're
looking to build your audience if you're
looking to get those first 1000
10 000 subscribers consider
making shorter videos instead of longer
videos because shorter videos are going
to help you reach new people and then
longer videos
are going to help you connect at a
deeper level once you've built
trust i mean this is the think marketing
podcast
these are you know 25-minute to
40-minute episodes
and this is kind of a different content
format because it's also not just in
video
but it's also on audio but you probably
wouldn't be hanging out with this long
form content
if you had it maybe seen a shorter
youtube video
first i kind of think about it like
dating you know what i mean like
if you are just meeting someone you
don't know them yet there's like speed
dating and that's your chance to
really take five minutes 10 minutes or
even just do a quick date like hey let's
just get
coffee to decide if you want to spend
longer time with that person
like usually sight unseen you're not
like hey do you want to spend the
weekend together like what if we just go
on a walk on the park saturday morning
we'll go grab tea and crumpets after
that who eats crumpets anymore then
we're in the afternoon you know we're
gonna we'll go to a matinee movie
after that we'll go on a carousel ride
and then we'll watch another movie and
then have a five course
what if you don't like the person's
personality you don't wanna be stuck in
that situation
so think about it like st shorter to
start
and then the relationship as it grows in
intimacy and trust
maybe somebody will hang out with you
for a 45 minute
hour and a half live stream and longer
form content on youtube if you're a
vlogger
any kind of content that you're creating
maybe a lot of times your content is 18
minutes
12 28 try making it four minutes and 21
seconds try making it
shorter and do some experiments and see
what the results are when you try making
shorter videos trimming the fluff
and powering up your content you know
the third change
that we've been focusing on here at
think media and our content on our main
channel
is powering up our content
i would ask how can i make my actual
videos
stronger this year how can i power them
up how can i upgrade them
you know if you're a gamer final fantasy
7 you get your materia and you put it in
your weapons right you level
up as you go in the game i don't know if
you're playing cyber
uh punk but you can get cyberware
upgrades and maybe you've got that
second heart or those gorilla arms right
as you progress
you're leveling up never get discouraged
with the level that you're at today
you still may feel a little
uncomfortable on camera you feel like
you have the best gear in the world
you you feel like you don't really know
editing that's fine
like just try to get one percent better
every time you upload a video
try to get one percent better as a
communicator or in your
the quality of your content but one of
our major focuses
is always trying to level up our content
and here's some ideas of how you could
do that you know one is b-roll and
visuals
it's one thing to open up a video with
talking head and say hey
this is what you're about to learn it's
a whole nother thing to actually show
what someone's about to see or learn
right it's like show and tell back in
first grade
remember i was so pumped to be able to
bring in my he-man masters of the
universe
to show and tell about i had the great i
actually had the grey skull thing
and i had the skeletor and you'd bring
in your stuff for show and tell
and it was one thing if i described the
he-man action figure it's a whole
another thing if i can show it
so this is what b-roll is those are the
visuals it's the clips
you know it's it's showing people up
front in the first few seconds of the
video
what they're maybe gonna see later in
the video it's kind of that
teaser reel and then b-roll throughout
again
if you just do talking head videos
challenge yourself maybe try to find
visuals
and you can do this with a website
that's like story
tape or or story blocks and these are
different b-roll websites where you can
actually
download visuals and clips that you
could include in your video another idea
is just your camera presence
are you working on being a better
communicator are you working on
and studying different books maybe a
book like talk like ted you know
learning from different ted talks listen
you don't got to read a book you could
just watch
a ted talk a day to try to say what is
it about
some of the most viewed ted talks that i
could learn from
in order to be a better communicator if
you want to be a better communicator
study good communicators
think about how you can level up your
on-camera presence another one is
preparation
you know the more preparation you have
going into your content the better
and if you show up unprepared people can
usually tell
and it actually causes you more stress
and more anxiety so your content will
get better the more prepared the more
you think things through
and maybe you're thinking through the
whole video you're thinking through okay
what am i going to be saying
what is the b-roll that we're going to
have in the video what are some props
you know
just preparing and thinking ahead
another one is organization
i've learned that to the degree that
you're organized
with your shoot day to the degree that
you're organized like
right now during this we're doing a
batch shoot of our podcast
and i've got a whole google doc here
it's on the ipad i've got the videos
organized
i brought in a couple changes of shirts
and jackets and whatnot
and i thought ahead of time to get
organized the think media team we got
omar kyle
they've got they're organized in how
we're going to save the con the whole
thing is going to help the content
be sharper because we try to approach
shoot day with greater organization
another one's third party data
i love this one of my favorite ways to
open up a video
is not just saying hey here's my opinion
of what's happening with the state of
youtube
but i like to open up a video to say i
don't know if you've seen this recent
article in emarketer but it showed us
that
adult social media consumption is
absolutely crushing
and it brings another level of authority
to a point you're maybe making
in a video third party data can you
integrate
news can you integrate an authoritative
resource so you're not like
hey this is my thoughts and uh you
should trust me they don't even know you
so third party data actually powers up
your content
because it gives it more authority and
more strength another one's just video
editing
editing your videos makes them stronger
you know a lot of times if you're just
free free-flowing and free talking
you can communicate pretty well but if
you trim the ums like i just had in this
if you like cut out the the pauses or
the mistakes or the moments especially
when you're just starting
don't put so much pressure on yourself
in the recording phase to get everything
right
remember that in the editing phase
things can be improved
music can help power up your content it
can set a mood it can bring energy
sound effects little swishes or sound
effects can actually keep people engaged
maybe we have a little subscribe button
that pops on screen there's a sound
effect the little like button that pops
on screen
some sound effects with that and then
also pacing
have you ever watched a movie or a
netflix show where you're like i kind of
want to hang with this thing
but like the pacing is off like i don't
know it really got slow in the middle
there
or like i like these actors but man the
pacing
of this video is off you know there's
something about
again just get one percent better with
every upload i know there's a lot of
ideas but i think these things can make
your videos stronger
and pacing is something to watch your
video back get feedback from others
think about how you can increase the
pacing you don't want it to be too fast
you definitely don't want it to be too
slow
you want ebbs and flows a good story has
you know a build it's got
you know an inciting event it's got a
climax it's got a little bit of
resolution maybe it has another climax
it creates drama there's different
pacing and certain moments in the video
where maybe you're trying to reengage
re-engage
attention these are just a few ideas of
powering up your content and if you want
to win on
youtube this year you're going to regret
just making the same content you made
yesterday
yesterday's homeruns will not win
today's game
and so think about leveling up your
content one percent per video and over a
year's time you're going to be amazed
by the level your content is at you know
the fourth thing is mastering hooks
we've been talking about this a lot of
course at think media and on think
marketing
we highly recommend the book hook point
by brendan kane and
you've heard him on the podcast and if
you missed that episode don't
miss that episode and we'll always link
up great resources like that in the show
notes
and descriptions everywhere but we're
really
thinking about hooks man we obsess about
hooks
to us this is actually the first really
30 to 60 seconds of the video
and there's actually data from youtube
new changes we're observing
where in your youtube analytics there's
a special tab
in the audience tab of your analytics
that shows you
how many percent of viewers are still
watching at 30 seconds
this is pretty insightful because if you
can't hold someone's attention for 30
seconds it maybe means
they clicked on the video but it it
didn't turn out to be what they thought
it was gonna be
you clicked on the video but you didn't
grab their attention or weren't able to
hold their attention
they clicked on the video and they
didn't like what they saw or whatever it
was
and what we're asking is man how do we
make those first 30 seconds even those
first 60 seconds
engaging how do we lead with
uh value how do we get attention
and really you know to do anything in
life
you got to get attention and sometimes
this can be a mindset where we actually
think nah
you know we're raised up like sit down
be humble like humility is not getting
attention but here's the deal
to do anything if you want to attract a
girl you need attention
if you want to stand out in a pile of
resumes you need
attention if you expect your business to
be profitable tomorrow
your business needs attention you have
to be able to figure out how to get
attention
and master hooks and of course we'll be
sharing more on this and even dedicating
whole episodes to this
but one quick power tip is what we're
focusing on and that's called the
value-based
hook we've been doing this at think
media and i think about a video omar did
with some lighting tips in the beginning
the video wasn't like in this video
you're going to be learning some
lighting tips and so stick around
and then there was like a little intro
and then like hey omar here
and then welcome to think media all
right let's get into tip number one and
it's already been like 30 45 seconds 60
seconds by the time you get to that
first tip
here's how the value based hook works
omar said
so one of the biggest mistakes that
people make with lighting
and then he revealed the mistake and he
actually put
tip number one which was in the form of
a mistake
first thing in the video right as the
video started mistake number one popped
up on screen in text and actually
got right into listen value that's why
it's a value-based hook
and so the structure was the opening was
tip number one
it was actually probably about 60
seconds of just going straight into
value right off the promise of the title
right off the promise of the thumbnail
and then there was the little think
stinger and it was like hey omar here if
you're
if you're new number two came later
and that was the value-based hook
and then number five is maintain
and amplify authenticity you know if you
want to win
on youtube and really make some
important changes
i think ask yourself the question am i
really being my authentic self on
youtube you know you want to make uh
i heard this quote make your life be as
awesome as you pretend it to be
on instagram isn't that true like
most of us when it comes to social media
we look at instagram we look at facebook
and and like most people's lives like
there's no way your life is that good
like bro you're not always at like the
beach and like oh it's so easy to just
carry my three kids around all day
like i have no problems right what are
people craving people are craving
real in a world of fake news fake
influencers
fake flexing on social media people are
craving
real and so in the midst of all the
tactics in the midst of all the
strategies in the midst
of all of the different ways to get
views and ways to go subscribers
i just want to encourage you tap into
your
authenticity be you times two you were
born an original
don't die a copy and remember
sally hogs had said different is better
than better you winning on youtube this
year is not trying to be the next mr
beast
or the next casey neistat or the next
marie forleo or the next heather taurus
or the next
whoever you winning on youtube this year
is being
different and being unique and the best
way to be unique
is to be yourself you know not
everyone's gonna like you not everyone's
gonna like me
that's okay your vibe is gonna attract
your tribe the key
is are you amplifying your vibe are you
really tapping into your quirks
your humor your personality because
tactics and a good title and a good
thumbnail
maybe may get someone to discover you
but it's your personality
that's ultimately going to get someone
to connect with you long
term and so make it a goal to not trying
to
impress people but actually make an
impact on people by being yourself
make your goal on youtube not to find
followers but to make friends
aren't we friends with the people that
are like dude i just get you and you're
going to get those negative comments
sometimes we're like
i don't like you but you're also gonna
get people who do never focus on the one
or two dislikes
the video got 12 likes you know got 120
likes and you're worried about the three
that click dislike
think about actually making friends that
connect with you
people that get you amplifying your
personality not just
gathering followers and it's really not
about popularity it's about authenticity
because we love connecting with people
who
are authentic when i think about
maintain and amplify your authenticity
i also think about two ways to really do
this
and its vulnerability and being
transparent i believe that vulnerability
and transparency are your superpowers
what does that mean
you don't need to flex and pretend you
just be transparent about
the truth aren't we hungry for real
truth
in today's world like people that are
just like like yeah
maybe you are having a lot of success
share that but also share your failures
i mean because life is real you know and
we all know that not everything is
rainbows and unicorns so when you're
vulnerable it's also saying that yeah
hey we're crushing it in business here
at think media but we also got problems
mo money mo problems you know at every
level you're trying to figure out
problems
with taxes or problems with team or
problems with finances or fires you got
to pull out
there's always going to be problems
don't be afraid to share
your transparent moments of course do it
from a place of
strength and healing and health i heard
it put it one way
share your scars not your open wounds
that if you're going to be authentic and
really vulnerable you know you don't
necessarily just vomit in your facebook
feed or in a youtube video you want to
make sure
you've maybe processed and you're in a
healthy place when you're vulnerable but
i've learned
that even some of the hardest seasons
that i've been scared of sharing whether
it was when my wife almost died or
whether it was
when we've gone through drama with our
church or a career or different things
that have happened
that man when i'm vulnerable about those
things that's some of the content that
resonates the most
so remember that vulnerability and
transparency are super powers
and guess what it is easiest to be 100
yourself the problem if you're not
authentic and you're not maintaining and
amplifying your authenticity
is you're ultimately creating some kind
of image or some kind of persona
what you're going to have to remember to
maintain
like i don't want to try to who am i
supposed to be tomorrow who am i
supposed to be on youtube i just want to
be myself
the easiest person to actually be is
myself because i don't have to overthink
it i don't have to
construct a lie i just have to be
myself and i really believe this that of
course when you level up and strengthen
some weaknesses and learn some tactics
and
get better at content and master hooks
and
power up things you got to learn some
stuff but when you amplify who you
really are
and when you also maintain your
authenticity when it's easy to get lost
in
trying to please followers or please the
algorithm or please other people
i just want to encourage you that real
lasting growth and legacy
comes from massive authenticity
well i hope that those five changes are
something that you're gonna make this
year maybe the first change you're gonna
make
is making shorter content versus longer
content you know for me specifically
right before we recorded this podcast
sean and i were having a conversation
where i was talking about my own channel
my own homeschool channel that i need to
be making content on
and i said i need to just apply this
shorter content versus longer content
and just get the videos
out i think this is going to help my
channel and i hope that that will help
your channel as well
and really i think the number five was
the biggest one which was
actually maintaining authenticity this
is something i have struggled with and
it's not because
i want to hide behind the camera but
sometimes it can feel scary to put
yourself out there and
make mistakes and say the um's and you
know uh
forget what you're supposed to say these
are all pieces of being a creator and i
think the more authentic you are
the more you share from your heart the
more you really let people into
your life and and what you're trying to
help them with
i think it's going to help your content
go a long way this year so i i'm hoping
that you've taken notes on all five of
those and
if you have not yet taken our think
master class this is a
hour class not on youtube you do need to
register for this free class so if
you've not already taken
the free youtube master class i highly
recommend that that be your next step
today
this one hour class is going to teach
you the three secrets to success on
youtube and what's working
right now you have these five pieces
that you need to change
but we want to tell you what really
works on youtube so make sure you take
that class
and at the end of that class we give you
the opportunity to join us in our
community called video ranking academy
so
i'm excited if you have not taken that
class for you to
do that next and uh if you have not
already
subscribed to the podcast you can
subscribe wherever you're listening from
we are so excited every time we get to
hear your reviews
in the comment section on youtube or on
apple itunes
it means the world to us that you would
let us know what you think about this
content
and maybe you'll get a shout out on our
podcast today's review
comes from tim from wales and he said
really great advice
having watched shawn and the team on
youtube it was only natural i was going
to carry over to listening to the
podcast
great job sean and heather sound advice
and tips
as we've come to expect really enjoy the
2020 lessons that you said
thank you so much tim for being a part
of our community and for sharing this
review
and if you have not already rated and
reviewed the podcast
i highly recommend that you go over and
do that so i can read your review
on the show and i really hope that you
tune in for next tuesday where sean
cannell is going to be sharing
how he built a 1 million subscriber
youtube channel
and he's really sharing an
unconventional strategy that he's never
shared before so make sure you tune in
next tuesday
thanks so much for being here and we'll
catch you on the next episode
you